eco's medicare your local medicare
benefit ecos medicare solutions excuse
me is back to help you save money on
prescription drugs take a look
[Music]
the loss of coverage or employer
coverage is a big deal
this year it's usually always a big deal
but this year
a lot of people because of kovid they've
lost their jobs so now they're losing
their employer coverage what does that
mean
if they're a senior now they gotta
acquire the part b
part of medicare they may have only had
part a but now they got to acquire part
b
so we can help them if they don't
understand how to get that we can help
them or they can go to the local social
security office or do it themselves on
online but we're here for to help them
with that and then
we have 63 days to get them enrolled in
a plan
once they lose their employer coverage
so this is very time sensitive again
it's 63 days
if you don't get it you have to wait all
the way till
the next period or next enrollment time
that you qualify for
here at ecos what we can do for someone
who loses their coverage
they can come in we will sit down with
them and like i said we can
we can do the part b paperwork with them
either
typically it's online we'll get the
forms for them give them to them so they
can deliver to their hr to get signed
that they actually did lose
and that their special election period
is valid because
social security is going to ask for that
before they'll send it off to medicare
to qualify them for their part
b is that they don't have if they don't
have this qualification period or
special election period
there's a penalty for part b that's ten
percent
every year or for every year you don't
have it so it's ten percent on top of
the 144 dollars the 60 cents the
government's gonna take anyways
for their part b so again time sensitive
so the the different options for for the
for these drug plans are many
you can you can stay with original
medicare and you can take a stand
stand-alone prescription drug plan
these prescription drug plans they do
have cost to them
and in they they have they have a huge
huge range so but what we'll do is we'll
sit down with you with the drugs that
you take or the rx
prescriptions and find the one that best
fits your needs the other option is to
get a medicare
advantage prescription drug plan mapd
what we call advantage plans or part c
those plans have them embedded in there
and
they come come with the medicare
prescription drug plan
and they're pretty rich formulary so
we'll have to see
sit down with our clients and see what
actually works best for them
you know we're a local company you know
every senior knows
does your phone ring yes every single
day multiple times a day
someone's trying to sell you medicare
insurance are they here locally
in las vegas or nevada do they do you
get
thousands of pieces of mail stacked up
this high in
in your mailbox every annual enrollment
period
how do you get sorted through all that
is it you call someone on the phone do
you get to meet with someone face to
face
well we're here to meet with you face to
face and answer your phone calls
at any time the phone number you're
gonna get is the same phone
that lays next to my bed every single
night
okay so you will get a hold of me
for more information call 702-277-4753
or just visit their website
ecos ecosmedicaresolutions.com